the death toll in the US has officially
reached more than a thousand with more
than 69,000 reported cases that is a lot
yesterday was a deadliest day in America
so far with about 250 deaths 13 of those
deaths were at the Elmhurst Hospital
right here in New York City where
doctors say their supplies are just
running out late last night the Senate
passed a two trillion dollar economic
stimulus bill including paychecks for
individual Americans and billions of
dollars in relief for medical providers
and businesses the bill now heads to the
house where it is expected to pass
tomorrow meanwhile dr. Anthony Fauci the
head of the National Institute of
Allergy and Infectious Diseases warns
there could be a second wave outbreak
right here in America as southern
hemisphere country's head into their
winter if in fact they have a
substantial outbreak it will be
inevitable that we need to be prepared
that will get a cycle around the second
time would this possibly become a
seasonal cyclic thing and I've always
indicated to you that I think it very
well might boy our dr. David agus joins
us once again from his home in Los
Angeles good morning to you David I want
to pick up with what Tony Fonda just
said hi that we should maybe get ready
for a second cycle and my question is
how in the world do we possibly begin to
prepare for that we're in the middle of
trying to figure out what this is that
we're dealing with right now remember I
mean things like the flu there are
multiple cycles right it comes and it
goes almost every week or every year but
we have a vaccine we have treatments
that work and our medical infrastructure
is ready for it the same is going to
happen here you know we were hit we were
blindsided by this we didn't know what
was coming we've taken dramatic measures
across the country now and we're going
to be ready for the second cycle I'm not
focused on that or worried about that I
just want to complete what we're doing
now and that the social distancing it is
starting to work you know it takes two
to nine days incubation period and then
the disease is 10 to 14 days and people
so we're gonna see the benefits of the
social distancing toward the end of this
coming week and the we
so we all have to hold tight doctor we
don't have great data on how widespread
the disease is the testing just isn't
available and yet we see these models
about when it's going to peak
how are those models built if we don't
have the underlying information nailed
down you hit it we are we are sorely
lacking data and you see models all over
the place you initially forty to seventy
percent of the globe will get it there
will be a catastrophic number of deaths
and then a Stanford a Nobel laureate
said well we're gonna actually doing
very well and over the next month or so
we're gonna see a dramatic decline you
know you see both angles and part of the
the aggressive models say we're not
going to have treatments we're not gonna
have care we're not gonna have a vaccine
coming along we're not going to be able
to handle this we're not going to social
distance but we are we are making the
impact that are going to prove the
aggressive models wrong the outcome is
gonna be better than that
and we're gonna get through this David
we've seen it spread so fast here in New
York City what concerns you most about
the possibility of it spreading in other
dense cities I love hearing from you
Anthony you know obviously New York City
we had said is the perfect place when
everybody's close to each other you look
at cities like LA San Francisco and
others there was a long period before we
social distance where the virus had an
opportunity to spread and it is going to
blossom in Los Angeles it is going to
blossom more in San Francisco we're
going to see obviously outbreaks that
follow New York in those cities we're
prepared for them now much better than
we were before and the social distancing
that we all did is going to start to
have its impact again the end of next
week
boy David can you just emphasize one
more time that social distancing is
working because I still see some people
knuckleheads I'll call them who haven't
gotten the memo it's very very upsetting
you're a hundred percent Ryan I mean it
is upsetting to see that but it is
working across the country it is the
dominant way we're gonna fight this
virus and what's amazing about it is
that people are stepping up there are a
few knuckleheads on beaches here and
there
but America through its part is doing it
and I'm proud of what America is doing
and the impact will be there we will
slow this virus we are slowing this
virus and it's frustrating because
there's a lag between what we're all
doing changing our life our interactions
and the effect on the virus but it is
happening and we will see it I promise
you it's happening all right I believe
you dr. David agus but we are a country
of hurry up make it up and now it
doesn't always work that way thank you
sir I know we'll see you later on